il y à 25 ans jour pour jour
disparaissait l'un des auteurs français
les plus lus au monde après jules verne
rené goscinny un des deux papa d'astérix
le scénariste a marqué à tout jamais la
bande dessinée en créant aussi et
notamment les histoires de lucky luke
un livre lui rend hommage l'album
goscinny sabine gorny change à petit de
cette machine à écrire à rêver sont nées
toutes les histoires les bulles qui nous
ont fait voyager enfants du phare ouest
d'où mon papa ou de lucky luke au palais
des mille et une nuits d'iznogoud d' en
passant bien sûr par la gaule et son
village d'irréductibles gaulois sont
fous ces romains
je vous signale qu'à scénario rené
goscinny est un scénario propre scénario
rené goscinny fait toujours rigoler
rené goscinny paris 16e rené goscinny le
scénariste de paris que la seine-et-oise
l'osr vie goscinny qui fanfaronne virl
elle angoissée à l'idée de la page
blanche lui le roi du calembour de la
phrase juste vu ce découpage messieurs
case par case image par image dans ses
archives soigneusement rangé un trésor
toute la vie de ces héros de papier
conservées par sa fille la gardienne du
temple
25 ans plus tard il continue à me faire
rire ça c'est quand même extraordinaire
quand on est quand on a plus on perd 2
il suffit d'ouvrir un album d'astérix un
livre du petit nicolas ou un album de
lucky luke au 19 août pour continuer à
se marrer je suis bien sûr il les lui
astérix l'antihéros le petit teigneux
courageux né dans pilote en 1959 et qui
fille d'uderzo et de goscinny deux
compagnons de gauloiseries chez moi dans
mon hlm de bobigny
on a démarré très bas et il m'a dit si
quale les époques historiques qui
peuvent cette intéressante et après les
hommes des cavernes chili les gaulois et
ma vie mais voilà les all whites hop on
plonge dedans et alain quart d'heure
tout atteste du scion foule c'est robin
tremblay un album plus tard astérix
s'est vendu à 300 millions d'exemplaires
dans le monde et il parle sans cette
langue pour bossini la belle histoire
s'arrête brusquement 77 en plein astérix
chez les belges
un titre que des réseaux finira seul et
qui ressort aujourd'hui en album
collector depuis même si leur aventure
se sont poursuivies de la mort de leur
papa nos deux héros ne se sont jamais
vraiment remis